katie right hey michael i really
appreciate what you've been saying
lately about denying money and business
to corporations that vocally disdain
conservatives and choose to go woke
i wish i could do this when it comes to
seemingly monopolized airlines i travel
regularly and have been loyal to
particular airlines for their quality
and prices
you can just say it's delta right you're
talking about delta because they have
high quality the prices aren't that
great but they're okay
but with everything from aggressive mass
rules in early 2020 to their recent
political behavior regarding voting
regulations i'm loathe to keep giving
them my business
do you foresee any alternatives for air
travel in the future where can i sign up
for air daily wire frequent flyer
program oh man if only how great would
that be
um you know if then we're flying you
just get there so much faster
and that somehow the announcements would
be even you know normally the airline
announcements are uh well uh
so uh we're about to uh touch down
but if it were banned i was like uh guys
the idea that we're gonna get here in
six hours is apparently ridiculous we're
gonna get there in four hours uh uh
so that would be great but the short
answer to your question is
the airlines are a little bit of a
racket they are
highly regulated it's hard for new
players to break into the market
and therefore withholding our money
is not probably going to be enough
what you're going to need to do is not
just exercise that kind of personal
cultural power
you also need to exercise political
power when you get into positions of
political authority
you need to make it really hard for
these airlines to operate
when they try to undermine your republic
now georgia's doing this to some effect
they're denying
delta some of their tax credits
okay great they've done that before it
hasn't bankrupted delta but if you had
broader political action on this front
then maybe you could get these woke
companies to stop
stop attacking your your way of life
because it's it's not just the fringe
cultural super duper conservatives who
are saying this sort of thing it's mitch
mcconnell mitch mcconnell is his
establishment as it gets but he's saying
you can't just give these guys a blank
check and allow
corporations to set up a parallel
government that's no good that's like
the worst possible situation so that's
what i would do i would flex political
power if we can ever get it again
and if we don't if we don't get voter
integrity back under control then who
knows if we will
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video